let's go next
why don't we go to Mike from
Massachusetts Mike welcome
hey David thanks for having me on
Pleasure
um I have a couple quick questions uh I
know you want to get to as many people
as possible but I'll try to make them
quick uh so while there's obviously
still some uh races out there that still
need to be called important ones
um clearly this was not the red wave
that the right was you know drooling
about no you know to totally dominate
Congress and you know block everything
for Joe Biden what do you think that I
mean what do you think the Democratic
like establishment is going to take away
from this because one thing that people
have pointed out is that the only senate
seat that so far they've been able to
flip was fetterman who ran on a
relatively Progressive agenda do you
think they take anything away from this
to take it in 2024 do they just continue
to keep the status quo because that's
just what they like to do unfortunately
or unfortunately depending on your
perspective I would say unfortunately
this was such a unique midterm and
you're right there's races where votes
are still being counted that I don't
think there is one big takeaway and the
truth is I've said for a long time
different types of Democrats make sense
in different parts of the country would
it be great to be able to run
progressives in every District every
Senate race and every governor's race
and win sure but that just simply
doesn't work that way you know up in
Massachusetts
um uh the governor's race Maura Healy
not like the Uber Progressive and when
you understand well Massachusetts has a
history
of more Centrist Democrats and
Republican Governors you have to kind of
say well if if we if we ran like a super
Progressive it might end up with another
Republican governor in Massachusetts I'm
sure you understand that and so
I'm sorry I was going to say in this
particular case for Massachusetts I mean
the Republican party went from a very
moderate like Baker and leaked all the
way to do a right-wing nut like Neil so
deal yeah I mean deal sorry yeah
um so I mean I don't I think it was
always a foregone conclusion that Maura
Healy had this one in the bag yes no
maybe it's not the best example this
particular year but it is sort of an
example so I think the takeaway from
four Democrats really needs to be uh
different different candidates in
different races can make sense
don't compromise on what are the most
important uniting values and I would say
one thing about fetterman you know I
don't there was this confusing moment
about fracking at the end of the day
fetterman said he's for fracking so it
he sort of backed off of as Progressive
a campaign as he had been running and I
know that there was some confusion
during the debate about that but he was
like no no I'm four fracking I'm four
fracking so did he really run as
progressively as maybe you're
characterizing I don't know but listen
it's a great thing that fetterman won
that's fair I I agree with that uh one
more if you'll allow me and I'll let you
move on
this one's probably gonna get a few eye
rolls from from the listeners but
I I've just been really thinking about
this and maybe the perspective has
changed since this election didn't go as
we thought it might but
I mean do you feel like as a country
we're approaching a position where
you know just based on the division that
we have they're reconcilable differences
I mean do you think we're approaching a
point where we have to have a legitimate
conversation about
doing do is it the best is it in the
everyone's best interest to keep the
country together I mean is do you think
we're approaching a point where we have
to have a legitimate conversation about
breaking the country up into two or more
pieces I don't and the reason why
honestly is exactly as you said two or
more there's a lack of contiguity in
exactly how you would do it even if we
agreed we've got to do it and it makes
sense which I don't believe anywhere
near a plurality of people are at
um I actually don't know geographically
that there's any you would end up
needing like six countries and obviously
that's not gonna happen you know
Fair it's just hard to it's hard to
imagine how we keep moving forward in a
positive direction yeah how do we live
with these people I mean it's an
alternate reality an alternate set of
moral values it's no bar is too low for
any candidate no matter what as long as
they're not a Democrat Herschel Walker
being the perfect example it's crazy I
share the the desperation I just don't
think chopping the country up into two
or more pieces is going to be a thing in
the next few years
I know and I don't know if that would be
the best move because that would remove
a serious roadblock for countries like
China and Russia absolutely you know
never mind the chaos it would reek
domestically
fair fair it's just it is hard to
imagine how we keep moving forward with
such drastic differences I'm with you
all right thank you for your time all
right thanks Mike from Massachusetts
great to hear from you